what do you think about what's going on
with Disney right now specifically
Disney it's it's weird to me that they
want to cater to the lowest percentage
of people in on the planet I mean you
know I
it's I I don't I don't understand it I
don't understand this wokeness thing I
think I always think I'm one of the
first people that could you know
attacked by the walk world in the
canceled culture in Hollywood 12 years
ago and they basically said we can't
work with anymore before it became a
term and uh I I honestly don't get it
you look at a movie like the top gun
Maverick movie it did so well because
people said here's just a movie that
just you know waves the flag certainly
it does but that's what Top Gun all
those things all about but it wasn't
pushing this agenda or pushing that
agenda we didn't even know who the enemy
was we know they didn't want to date for
they didn't want to do that either but
you know but at the same time it was
just a movie that was just fun to watch
and it was just uh you know it did so
well because it catered to the audience
that still wants to go see theaters yeah
I don't you know people get mad there
was a movie was this the one that had
the gay relationship in or something so
they get mad because people don't want
to see that and you're going well let
people see what they want to see I
thought there's supposed to be a free
country and we're supposed to go what do
we want you know oh yeah yeah I'm not
telling Disney not to do what they're
doing with the movies but that why am I
doing movies that are totally opposite
that have Love and Hope and laughed and
Redemption those are the kind of movies
I want to do and those are the movies
that people keep telling me to make but
I don't have a 100 million dollar budget
like they do to advertise it because
they did that's what they did a movie
like that needs to get to about 500 600
million dollars to break even and that's
why they keep doing movies like Avatar
and Avengers and things like that they
need to get to that level but they're
going to make two billion dollars in
theaters they're gonna make Pirates of
the Caribbean 14. they're going to keep
making these movies
and they'll keep doing it so you you
think Johnny Depp to 300 million dollars
to do pirates of the Cure probably and
you think he's gonna accept it probably
you might have heard he's had some legal
troubles yeah but when you said you said
the term they keep playing to the lowest
percentage of people what do you mean by
that exactly well it just seems like
they wanted okay what what percentage of
the population is transgender 0.5
yeah exactly fine people want to do
their life fine I I'm not racist towards
that or hate people that go through that
in fact I feel sorry for some because
what I've read about it they go through
a lot of things psychologically as well
a lot of trauma yeah a lot of trauma in
this world and then the gay population I
love when they call me homophobe I've
been in the business 40 years I work
with gay people in every set I've been
on you won't find one that said he was
so mean to me they won't but it's easy
just being a conservative is enough for
them to say oh he hates gay people no we
don't but it's easy to have that Mark
and they have their labels but that's
all they have is their labels they don't
have things to back it up they have
these little labels that the media tells
them to say you're racist you're a
homophobe you're anti-semit they say all
this stuff well they're actually the
ones that are anti-semite but anyway
it's a weird world out there right now
where they come after you for anything I
mean the people that attack me on
Twitter I can say great day in the golf
course I hope you die you know these
these people have nothing better to do
with their lives and to me I feel more
sad for them I don't feel anger towards
them I feel like my God what kind of
Life did they lead when they got to wake
up every morning look in the mirror and
hey what they see what a horrible way to
go through life every day you're saying
like the law of large numbers that point
five percent 5 two percent whatever the
number is they're catering to that
audience then the 90 plus percent you
know which is weird yeah it's called the
loudest what business are you in you're
in what business the life insurance
business but you're not you're not just
in the Life Insurance business the life
settlement business correct okay so life
settlement imagine if you started
targeting 20 year olds yes and your
commercials for Life settlement which is
what for clients that are above 78 let's
just say right seven five and up right
correct correct imagine if these life
settlement companies started targeting
18 year old kids saying you think about
your life insurance policy 18 year old
kids can say what the hell I guarantee
you ninety percent of people listening
to this right now don't even know what
life settlement is correct like I'm
sorry Google here's what life settlement
is you're 75 years old you have a 5
million auto insurance policy you got a
two million dollar insurance policy
everybody you love is no longer alive
and your kids who you had insurance for
no longer need insurance because they're
married their career is fine they're
doing good but your premium used to be
200 a month now it's 500 a month now
it's two thousand dollars a month you
can't afford it so you got five million
dollars a guy like this comes up to you
and says listen I'll pay you eighteen
percent for your two million dollar
policy you're paying however much money
I'll pay you 18 for it what's 18 360 000
here give us a two million dollar
insurance policy we'll pay the premium
you're 78 years old based on your life
expectance you're gonna die at 85 we'll
take the risk okay cool 360 I'm alive I
get the two million dollar policy I'll
make the exchange right if an insurance
company targeted 18 year olds that's
stupid practice okay and that's what
Disney's doing so on the capitalism side
it's dumb practice because capitalism
eventually exposes dumb ideas and
Disney's getting exposed for dumb ideas
Bob shape where they had to beg a bob
Iger to come back which Bob Iger is
sitting there saying I may have some
political aspirations that he has to put
on pause because the guy went from being
a Democrat to apparently is a more in
the independent middle right now and he
was kind of having the conversation when
he was my 21st Century Fox when Murdoch
asked him and said hey any aspirations
are running for office not really even
who was thinking about running for
president well Bob Iger save it then
there's the other part so one is
capitalism he's going to expose you know
what the other part is here's the other
part
sitting there with the movie it's
literally the scene when it happens so
so far I'm trying to figure out what's
going on with this cartoon it's actually
like watching cartoons I like cartoons
I'm the 44 year old guy that likes
watching a good cartoon and then all of
a sudden you see this uh 10 year old kid
blushing when another 10 year old kid
what highlight shows up it's like oh my
God and I'm like wait what and they come
like I'll keep I said okay I get you
what you're trying to do you want to say
that we have a high Dei score because
everything you have meets the guidelines
of that Community okay one uh don't
forget who your customers are kids are
not buying 20 tickets parents are you're
an idiot if you think parents are going
to sit there most parents are going to
sit there and say well you know what
it's okay now a lot of parents are gonna
say no it's not okay and then they're
going to go to a different place order
your future looks bright hat click over
here and to watch the entire podcast
click here take care everybody
foreign
[Music]